people the reason so many people  struggle with entrepreneurship  is you have micro failures almost daily  and they're very in your face you can't  hide  and uh i like that uh i like failure i  because i think i deserve it i hate when  people don't respect the game  when i fail it means i [ __ ] up  and i like that because i think people  get audacious my number one thing that i  hate about capitalism  is that people use it and they love it  and they're big capitalists  and they love open market and  competition and all that and then they  become 73  and they try to use all their money to  protect their money they're not willing  to let a young lion  eat them the way they ate somebody else  i hate when they try to manipulate it